our next speaker
was formerly a professional opera singer
for a children's group you want to make
sure that counted so everyone please
welcome Emily
hi everyone my name is Emily reuter I
chose my walk-on song today because
entered bad column names hoping that's
given me at least three good stories to
share with you all at this conference
and with that I'm here to talk about
translating column name contracts from D
plier which helped me it shaped a lot of
my ideas in the space to DBT which is
another open source tool that I've
become quite a fan of using and how I
did that through the package I developed
called DBT plier
so
I think all of us have probably seen
many different variants of really bad
column names and data sets we've worked
with they can really trip up trip us up
when trying to do analysis
everything from the order of different
naming components inconsistencies and
how things are abbreviated or what
different quantities mean and represent
how they're cased within code or even in
the K on the opposite end of the
spectrum variable names in maybe stats
or in Census Data that's incredibly
specific but at the other end of the
spectrum has no intrinsic human meaning
and I think early in my career I just
kind of accepted this as part for the
course until D plier taught me to expect
more and to really think about how we
could be better communicating through
every single part of what we do with
data so the three stories I want to tell
today is first how the
depliers API really inspired my thinking
about column naming
as a data scientist secondly how I
adapted that is my team moved more into
the data engineering space to help
communicate intensive meaning with
others and finally then as a data tool
developer how I brought these Concepts
along with me into DBT with the DB prior
package
so starting off at the beginning many of
you may have seen deep pliers Rich set
of Select helper functionality these
include helper functions like starts
with ends with contains that help us
select out a set of variables which we
want to transform based on components of
their name and the first time I saw this
in dpliers API it was really kind of an
eye-opening experience just because it
was the first time that I started
thinking that I could and should be able
to expect more from my variable names
declared like thought and craved for
there to be some intrinsic meaning in
those and I kind of realized I did too
and this really started to shape some of
the workflow and some of the ways that I
approached my analysis and writing code
really across the r and especially the
Thai diverse ecosystem for better data
transformation in deep plier data
modeling and predictive analysis with
recipes and tidy models and data
validation with Point Blank
so first I'll just give a few examples
of how I started to use this in my own
work to kind of motivate the transition
and the mindset switch that I went
through
to just start with a very basic example
with d plier
um by encoding I I found that if I
started to like rename and manipulate
some of the data I was working with I
could capture types of data in those
column names to be able to program
against them in a more Dynamic fashion
so for example if I wanted to take be
able to take the mean of all indicator
variables and calculate a lot of
proportions of different event rates by
starting all my variable names with some
common prefix like end it made it easy
to select all of those out in a data
Pipeline and apply that same mean
transformation to them all and similarly
using other things like being able to
grab out different revenue or cost
metrics and sum them all up
and of course in D player you can go one
step fancier than this once you take the
mean of an indicator variable it's
actually a proportion not an indicator
so you can go ahead and dynamically
rename those columns while you're at it
but over time I found that Beyond D
plier I could actually accomplish a lot
more even more like valuable and
meaningful tasks with this workflow so
for example when we think about
predictive modeling it can often be
really useful to bring post-action
variables of some future event we're
trying to predict into our modeling
Pipeline and preserve that information
to help us detect weak spots in that
model and understand more deeper details
about its performance Diagnostics but of
course we know that we want to make sure
those aren't included as predictors that
could risk future leakage
so to do that again by specifying the
intent of our variables in our column
names such as pre-variables and post
variables I could very easily select out
all of those variables that captured
some post-action con context
update their role with the recipes
package to ensure that they were not
considered a predictor when I ended up
building that model
and then finally I think one of my other
favorite applications for really
exploding value of column names is in
data validation I'm a big fan of the
point-blank package and by
using the same pattern there I could
very easily check all of my variables at
the same time without having trade a lot
of redundant code checking for every
single end variable is that variable
greater than or greater than zero which
it probably should be if it represents
account
and this also makes my the code Wonder
it's a lot more dynamic because then if
I added two or three or four variables
to my data set later on in the process
those new variables would already be
captured in the checks and automatically
vacuumed up I wouldn't have to remember
to go manually add in more information
later
so I found this to be a very effective
pattern to use in my own work as an
analyst but over time and I found that I
probably wasn't alone in this
at first when I used other languages
such as pandas
I used to kind of like mock up the same
workflow
um just using a basic list comprehension
Andrew Jackson says to identify
these column name patterns but I noticed
recently in the new polars package that
polar is much like the plier now include
some of these column name selectors as
first class citizens in one of its
modules
so while I found this work really useful
to myself as
an analyst and it was something that
deployers syntax really taught me and
really got me thinking about I started
thinking about how I could use it the
same kind of pattern and the language of
column names to communicate to other
people not just to myself
and is my responsibilities began to
include more data production
I tried to think about how to use this
pattern as a data producer to help other
people understand the intent of the data
that I was producing
and I came up with this idea of really
fully thinking regarding column names as
the user interface of our data there's a
thing we get to touch and feel and play
with whereas the functionality of a data
set the actual values themselves are
hidden under the surface in abstracted
way and something that we aren't always
staring at
um on their face
so for building new data sets and um
publishing kind of full data Marts and
data warehouses I started to take a
two-step approach
where first my team and I would Define
simple stubs that really encoded some of
these semantics and contracts and
Contours of the data that we might want
to be able to operate on at a later
point in the process
and then when going to name column names
across different data sets
we try to rely only on these stubs and
permute them in different ways to
capture really rich and comprehensive
set of characteristics but that were
automatically very human interpretable
so just think of one example of this and
this certainly isn't the only way you
can set up this sort of structure just
one that I happen to like you can
imagine a first layer being kind of a
type layer and I don't mean that in an
inch string float very like programming
language idea of types but combining
data types with their intent so for
example for each stub like ID and Bin we
can attach specific semantics to them so
for example we know an indicator
variable is the binary zero one variable
and that the rest of the name always
encodes that positive one condition so
we don't have this ambiguity of like
which is the one which is the zero
but beyond semantics what I think is
even more powerful is that we can use
this same approach to embed performance
contracts and sort of implicit data
quality guarantees for any variables
that have that
um have the certain names and steps
attached to them
so for example you might see here that
Indian bin actually have the same
semantic definition
of between those two variables but in
incomes with the additional guarantee
that it's not null and as we'll see in a
minute that can have important
um implications for how you use the data
and similarly you can do other things
like making sure date variables are
always cast in a certain format
and again you can imagine this going on
to defining subsequent layers of steps
so perhaps more of an entity layer where
you characterize things like users and
logins that are kind of those classic
examples of things that many different
business units can often Define
differently in their data sets you can
imagine many different ways you could
characterize what actually constitutes
the event of a login
but you can use this defining such
vocabulary is an opportunity to bring
your data producers and your data
consumers and different stakeholders
together enforce alignment on one single
definition
and once you have those definitions
Beyond contracts you can also think
about those consequences and document
those as well
such as making sure that um
like such as if you're defining a user
based on IP address you know that may
not always capture users consistently
across devices
so the Australia aluminates a lot of
ambiguity around what certain Concepts
in your data are meaning
and finally you can imagine going many
layers deep into this process and having
all of these little Legos and building
blocks that you can put together into
seamless and clear set of names
and this I think can really help
communicate again not only to yourself
reminding yourself what you're doing but
Bridging the Gap between data producers
and data consumers
so for example if I make a data set just
with a login variable and some other
user tries to use that to calculate a
login rate if they don't know how that's
encoded they maybe don't know whether or
not their nulls in that data set
but if they know if it's an end or bin
variable they actually know what they're
working with and Beyond just like
tripping over some null values I think
that can have pretty important impact
for an overall analysis because for
example if a login variable is only
recorded if someone passed the capture
check
if you try to calculate the same
proportion on an indiv variable versus
bin variable simply by taking the mean
in one case you're calculating the
proportion of successful logins and the
other you're actually calculating a
conditional probability
so not only are you having a slight data
quality error but you're actually
fundamentally changing your s demand but
with clear column names you can really
just avoid that confusion it's zero
mental friction
so I've talked about how an API inspired
how I thought about using column names
to communicate meaning how I then
started to use column names in my own
work to help other users
but then finally putting on back my data
developer at data tool developer hat
I wanted to take what I'd learned and
share it with the broader data community
and Export that API that had taught me
so much about language and embedded
meaning in code to another language so
that's why I decided to translate these
select helpers to DBT in my DBT prior
package
so a few brief words on DBT going back
to the theme that Jared mentioned at the
beginning of the day about art and
Friends DBT is another tool that I've
become
um really enamored of and I think has a
lot of spiritual similarity with some of
the nice aspects of the art community in
terms of the things we tend to value in
our code
it essentially helps bring more software
engineering best practices to SQL based
workflows by promoting things like clean
code bringing things like uh control
flow variables ability to write
functions to SQL it helps you better
organize SQL based data pipelines into
projects by decomposing complex queries
into monolithic pipelines adding the
ability to have a standardized folder
structure and to unbed testing Version
Control
Etc and finally it brings better
developer tools like being able to have
isolated different environments in a
database
adding in pipeline testing orchestration
and logging
and just to give like the briefest
surface level example of how DBT and
compares to SQL we can see a standard
SQL script on the left hand side of the
screen where we have a lot of really
redundant code a lot of room for copy
and paste stairs a lot of repeated
business logic but then with some of the
features that DBT brings to SQL we can
get right get to something a little bit
more like what we see on Direct
where we can set variables iterate over
them to eliminate our redundant and
repeated code and to find macros to
encapsulate some of that business logic
into functions
so with this ability to kind of move
beyond the basics of clumsy clunky SQL
based data Pipelines
the next thing I really craved was some
of these higher levels semantic
functionality that I had in DB flyer
when working with r
also when I was working in DBT
and that's what inspired me to write DBT
plier where I ported all of those
functions that I talked about earlier as
being so critical to My Thai diverse
based workflows into DBT
it so just to give a brief example of
what this looks like
um in a now SQL pipeline what I could do
is something like extract all of the
variables from my data set identify all
of those variables that match a certain
pattern
then my slot statement in a single line
of code I could apply with the across
macro the same transformation to all of
those variables and rename them
accordingly
and similarly do similar things in a
where clause
and
just and this is like I think has many
different benefits even more than I
initially expected in the data pipeline
space
so first it could avoid that one key
challenge that I mentioned of column
names which is how inconsistent they can
be in terms of typos and ordering of
components I'm sure we've all felt the
demanding experience of having our code
break because we failed to correctly
create the same type of error that
existed in an upstream data set
but simply by using DBT
we're able to avoid this sort of um
inconsistencies by
um instead of writing this really
redundant code like you'd see on the
right hand side where every single
variable we create there's kind of that
equal probability of introducing some
typo
by again moving back to a workflow with
more of that control flow where we can
Define set variables simply Loop over
them write them once for very consistent
names
but of course even worse than having
those kind of inconsistencies is when
we're actively lying to our users like
when we have the second case I talked
about earlier where
um we maybe have a date variable that
actually represents something like a
timestamp because that can create
massive liability and Analysis if you
filter by that data as if it were a date
you could actually be throwing away
all of your records because none of them
would be direct matches
and this is where the power of something
like DBT with DBT prior really comes
into effect if we wanted to actively
cast all of the variables that should be
dates to dates
we can do that using these select
helpers by selecting out all the columns
from our Upstream data which we intend
to assert our dates and simply applying
the date transformation
in casting operation continuously across
all of them
and again this is a very resilient way
to go about it because if an upstream
table later on adds one more date
variable it will automatically get
vacuumed up and the same transformation
will be applied to it we don't have to
remember to do that at every single step
of our pipeline
but we all know that automation creates
some risks of its own
this would be a slightly dicer operation
to cast all numeric columns to be
integers because if some of those
columns weren't actually integers if
something had happened Upstream in the
pipeline and something was going wrong
by doing this automatic casting
operation we wouldn't be fixing an error
we'd actually just be covering up and
making it sort of undetectable in our
data pipeline
so we can also embed these column name
contracts and checks in dbts in pipeline
testing
so ddta has the ability to add data
checks in your data pipeline by writing
queries that should return no results
unless they're anomalies so we might
want to write a query that only returns
records that have variables that are
named as integers but aren't
sufficiently integer-like
but again if we wrote something like
this could be very brittle could be very
hard to maintain
instead final pattern that I've tended
to use a lot with the DBT plier package
is to once again identify all those
columns that need a pattern and
automatically generate tests that have
full coverage across my entire data set
um identify once apply across
so those that concludes the three
stories that the over 100 bad column
names that I've encountered in my work
really encapsulated for me what dpliers
API taught me about better column naming
what I've learned about Community using
column naming as an API and how I've
shared that from our into the DVT
ecosystem
if you're interested in exploring these
topics more or learning more about DBT
in general linked a number of resources
at the end of my deck and happy to chat
anytime in the next couple of days thank
you
[Applause]